how to eat a burger I just dean style
step 1 go get that burger hi hi welcome
to Carl's jr. what can I get for you
today
hmm I'll have to look pay that'll be $4
wait well I didn't order yet yeah well
you look like you want a new burger what
does one look like who wants your new
burger like you oh do you want to drink
with you yeah I'll take a drink but I
don't know what I'm having it with our
new portobello mushroom $6 burger with
Swiss cheese sliced portobello mushrooms
a hundred percent Charbroil Angus beef
all piled high on a chip dude fun Oh
sounds really good I'll take it
Thanks
step 2 get out all of your burger eating
utensils step 3
begin analyzing the burger to get it
prepped for the ketchup step 4 remove
the bun and distribute ketchup to the
top of the burger evenly lots of ketchup
but don't forget to put a little extra
on the side for dipping cut in half and
enjoy
privacy please
oh and step 6 place bond aside and save
it for later for a late night snack how
do you reach your burger maker response
fit and how you eat yours